تقليل إعادة الاستخدام، إعادة التدوير، إعادة
التدوير أمر مهم، تقليل إعادة الاستخدام، إعادة التدوير، لقد
كانت هذه العادات الخضراء الثلاثة جزءًا من
حياتنا اليومية منذ إعادة التدوير في سبعينيات القرن العشرين، فنحن نقوم بإعادة التدوير،
القوة في يدك، ولكن يبدو أن
الكثير منا لا يزال في حيرة من أمره بشأن أحد
هذه
العناصر، وهو تقرير من إحدى المنظمات غير الحكومية  يقول أن أكثر من
نصف المواد المنزلية القابلة لإعادة التدوير ينتهي بها الأمر في سلة
المهملات، تعتقد أنك تعرف القواعد جيدًا،
ماذا عن قطعة الورق المقوى
هذه؟  لإعادة
التدوير ولكن الآخرين لا يفعلون ذلك لأنهم
يعتبرون الشحوم بمثابة
تلوث غذائي، لذا فالأمر ليس بهذه البساطة كما
قد تظن، فكل هذه العناصر مصنوعة
من مواد يمكن إعادة تدويرها ولكن
هناك بعض القواعد الذهبية التي يجب تذكرها
إذا كان هناك بقايا طعام على أحد العناصر  ثم
لا يمكن أن تدخل في عملية إعادة التدوير، قم بشطفها
أولاً، الأمر نفسه بالنسبة للمواد المختلطة
مثل الشريط اللاصق على الورق المقوى، يجب عليك
إزالته قبل
إعادة التدوير، عندما يتم طرح شيء ما في
إعادة التدوير ولا ينبغي أن يكون موجودًا، يمكن أن
يلوث
النظام بأكمله مصنع إعادة التدوير هذا  تقوم لندن بفرز
أكثر من 400 طن من النفايات يوميًا،
والتلوث هو المكان الذي توجد فيه
أشياء لا ينبغي أن تكون موجودة في إعادة تدوير المزيج الجاف،
مثل نفايات الطعام على سبيل المثال، حيث
ستؤدي نفايات الطعام إلى تلويث
المواد الأخرى في إعادة تدوير الورق و
الورق المقوى وجعله عديم الفائدة ولكن من
الواضح أن العناصر الأخرى يمكن أن
تسبب انسدادًا داخل
الآلات المعقدة ولحسن الحظ، هناك بعض
النصائح المفيدة لمساعدتك في اتخاذ
القرارات الصحيحة، الأول هو اختبار المسح
لأشياء مثل حزم Cris أو
ورق التغليف التي هي  غالبًا ما يتم خلطه بمواد أخرى
إذا سحقته في يدك
وظل مخدوشًا، فمن المحتمل أن يكون
قابلاً لإعادة التدوير إذا بدأ في الفتح، فمن
المحتمل أن يحتاج إلى وضعه في سلة
المهملات إذا كان بإمكانك قلب العنصر رأسًا على
عقب وربما حتى فوق رأسك ولم
يخرج شيء منك  "إنها جيدة إذا لم يتم
شطفها
مرة أخرى بالعديد من الرموز والقواعد
والعلاقات التنظيمية التي لا تختلف فقط من
بلد إلى آخر ولكن من منطقة إلى أخرى،
فليس من المستغرب أننا غالبًا ما نشعر
بالارتباك، فهناك الكثير من الالتباس
حول إعادة التدوير لأن صناعتنا
تتغير باستمرار إلى الأفضل  النصيحة التي
يمكنني تقديمها للأشخاص في المنزل هي الانتقال إلى
الموقع الإلكتروني للسلطة المحلية الخاصة بك.
يبذل الكثير منا قصارى جهدهم
ولكن يمكنهم عن غير قصد القيام بشيء
يسمى ركوب الرغبات
ويمكن أن يضر ذلك أكثر مما ينفع إذا
لم تكن متأكدًا من شيء ما، ضعه
في سلة المهملات وليس في سلة إعادة التدوير
لأنك ستسبب
مشكلة، لذا تذكر التحقق من الملصقات
بشكل صحيح وشطف بقايا الطعام وتأكد مما إذا
كنت تتعامل مع مواد مختلطة
وحاول ألا ترغب في التخلص من مسؤوليات إعادة التدوير الخاصة بك
وتحقق عبر الإنترنت من
السلطة المحلية الخاصة بك  إذا لم تكن متأكدا